face à la pandémie qui touche plus d'une
centaines de vénézuéliens le pays
affiche des signes de pénurie les
mesures décrétées le 17 mars par
nicholas maduro n'empêche pas la
population de sortir à la fois à la
recherche de produits ménagers comme le
savon et la lessive mais également pour
de l'essence des marchandises de plus en
plus rare étant donné que le pays n'est
plus fournie convenablement les
vénézuéliens sont donc obligés de braver
le confinement
je suis allé dans plusieurs stations
essence et elles sont fermées où elles
ne m'ont pas aidé parce que je suis
médecin à rien seulement pour les
militaires dans plusieurs stations ils
m'ont dit seulement pour les militaires
j'ai présenté mes diplômes de l'école de
médecine est rien ils ne m'ont pas aidé
on ne peut pas laver nos vêtements parce
que l'on n'arrive pas lot comprend ici
c'est juste de l'eau pour l'essentiel la
douche et c'est tout car malheureusement
on n'a pas de citernes pour laver nos
vêtements ou pour le ménage en général
la semaine dernière caracas a reçu 55
tonnes des d'envoyer par la chine
une aide qui comprenait uniquement du
matériel médical notamment des kits de
test rapide et des médicaments
cinq cent mille kits de test rapide sont
arrivés les premiers 500 mille kits de
test rapide pour l'offensive
la prochaine étape pour nous est de
contrôler et de prévenir le coït 19 face
à la crise sanitaire
le président vénézuélien mise sur une
quarantaine sociale collective et
volontaire nicolás maduro multiplié les
échanges avec l'extérieur afin de
récolter des soutiens précieux dans sa
lutte contre le coronavirus j'ai reçu le
message du frère président vladimir
poutine qui a confirmé son soutien
stratégique global dans tous les
domaines des changes
j'ai également parlé avec antonio
gutiérrez secrétaire général de l'onu
qui a exprimé son soutien humanitaire
pour affronter le co by 19 ans plus
d'une inflation importante synonyme de
pire crise économique de son histoire le
venezuela se prépare donc à affronter
impossible désastre sanitaire
malgré cette terrible menace les
etats-unis ont décidé de poursuivre
leurs sanctions contre le pays
un choix qui va à l'encontre de l'esprit
humanitaire fondamentale selon un porte
parole de la diplomatie chinoise